Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Insanity Clicker.
Now this is a bizarre game...
I-It actually has such a unique- oh hey,
how's it goin' there? It actually has such a unique premise...
that I just had to play it. It's a clicker game. Like, Cookie Clicker, clicker game.
What are you doing?! Can you stop jumping at me?
And you click, and click, and click, click, click...
and then they die. And then you get presented with
a new monster, and you keep clicking- thank you tooth- and you keep clicking, until they
all die, and you progressively
get stronger, and stronger...
as you go through the game.
Alright, so basically, I just started the game
I had to load in because it wouldn't even
give me any settings before I started playing, but-
Habuh! Buh, buh ba beh!
*character screaming*
Sorry lady! Oh, hey, you look cool.
The thing about it is, I-I've been cycling through some of the
monsters. Some of these monsters are like,
really well designed, like,
I dunno what this guy's story is, but he is
reeeaally cool! I mean a lot of these
monsters are just bizarre, and
weird, and apparently they're part of your mind,
and apparently there's a whole 'meta-game,'
uh, that further expands what you do
in this, and I have no idea what that is,
so we're gonna explore it together.
*character groans*
But like I said, this game is free, so...
Why the hell not? You don't even look like a monster!
You're just a normal person that was in the wrong place at the wrong time!
Sorry, okay, you're a monster, you're definitely 'Ran-o-car.'
Ohohoho, what are you?
Oh, man! I've been p- I've been cycling through quite a few enemies,
I haven't seen these guys before. This is weird.
Oh, heeeeyyyy!
*laughing* How's it goin' there?
Alright, goodbye! Oh!
Nice balancing on the sword act.
To bad it's t- ohhhhhhh, what are you?!
Oh my god is that's what's gonna happen to me
in 50 years? When I become ingrained on the internet, and I just get absorbed
into my computer? Probably.
Boink.
Euuuooooh no! You're pregnant!
Oh! I don't know- wanna know what with!
Euugh! Hi!
Oh, you look relatively okay, and
friendly... eugh.
Ohh... you wanna hug?
You wanna hug lady? Alright, too
bad, all I have is death.
Oh... That is...
Euuoouughh!
Ohh, I can get a scorpion!
I don't know what the uh... I think it just increases
my damage. Ha buh!
Uhh... I got a cobra!
Oh! Oh, my cobra!
Well jeez! No! I don't even get to talk to them anymore!!
Hiiii!
H'okay Byyhehehe! Okay, So I'm gonna
go up to the next level now, because I got this
new level in a while, and I'm doing a little
too much damage, so... Let's say hi
to the higher level guys, and hopefully get some more
teeth out of it. So you go-
i-i-in the top bar, you can see the numbers-
Plague doctor! Welcome to the party!
Why are you ball and chained?
You married? *chuckles*
Habada habada. Oh you're new!
Oh man! These guys die so quick, I don't even know
what the hell they are.
Alright, whatever.
Why are these guys- Wooaahh! You look like the guy from
Resident Evil! Nightmare!
Nightmare? Nightmare! Oh!
I unlocked a new floor, let's go up to the
harder one. Hiiiii!
What are you?!
Ah, Uberton!
Oh, hey Uberton! How you doin'?
Awh That's so- that's so cool!
Euuuwhh, EUhWaah!
EUghWagHh EauauaaWaa!!
Me no likey that. Go away please.
Thank you.
Are there, like, new monsters on every single level?
That would be so- Whoah what are you??
Woah, what are you? What are you? What are you?? What is that??!!
What is that??!  To the right, what is that?? What is that?? Should I be worried about that?
Or is that okay?
I guess it's okay?
Alright, bye buddy. Oh you're,- you're the
same old guy that we've seen before.
'Kay.
*character screams*
Man, oh hello!
You look like one of the Silent Hill nurses!
Joan Jane? That's your name?!
Joan Jane?! Alright, whatever.
Ooohh man. Oh no!
Creepy little girl!! Everybody run away!
As fast as you can!
My minsterfs streak
Euuuah Cerberator
What's a Cerberator??
I-I don't wanna know what a Cerberator-
Hello T.V. hacker.
Is that really your name? T.V. hacker?
That's a good name, good name buddy.
AaaAh! AAHaAAaAaaaHaHHhh!! It's grandma!!
Grandma! I don't want to visit you right now!
Sorry, Goodbye!
EuuEugh!
OOOooooh Heheheheeeeyy!
How you doin'?
OOoooh
Kjon Chin?
With your s- oh hey...
Zackervivvveh...
Hubeduh. I still don't- oh...
Fu- flurry of blows? I didn't do that!
I didn't do that!! Oh god!!!
I don't know what happened, bye!
OOOOoooh you all look so friendly!
and now you look so dead... oh my god...
Oh you're- ohkay...
Euuugh!
*grunts*
You just go- Oh hey!! Hi!
"Boss Suck?" Boss?
Oh I should- I should probably help out about this.
AAAaaaaaaaaaaaAAAhAhHHhhh!!!!
Lemme get double clickin' here.
The HunieCam has trained me for this!
Oh shit
What do I-  just gotta beat her up over and over again?
Wooooooah! Wow! that is a lot of blood
*laughing* That is too much blood!
OOOOooooh!
Alright,
Okay then
What happens if I lose this boss?
Do I just not get anything out of it?
"Pet unlocked: Sundew"
Well that's an awfully cheerful name, for what
amounts to a horrible monstrosity
over there, I don't think I want that.
Let's see, what would the scorpion do?
Ooh, scorpion just does damage like everything else I suppose
Oof
Alright, I'm gonna see what happens if I
don't beat "Boss Suck."
Anything?
Oh!
Hello "Harerean!"
"Herrarine?" What the hell happened to me?
I don't know what you are. I don't know why you got glass.
Why is your weapon just this broken, wooden stool?
That's not gonna do anything to anybody.
Oh hey buddy
It's my old friend
OOOOooooh you're new!
Alright, we're goin' to the next floor.
OOooooh!
What are youuuu??
"Diabolic pentagram."
Okay?
You look interesting
but I'm kinda interested, in like,
the environment that we're in now.
Also, I seem to be traversing a lot of this asylum and I don't know how much
Like, there is to this place
But is actually pretty cool; I have to admit
For a free game
This is neato
This is neato kabido
Like I appreciate the fact that they've made so many of these garish, ghoulish enemies
There's just a HUUUUGE variety of it.
Ooooh, and always YOU, okay... goodbye
Alright, I need some upgrades
Let's see...that...upgrade my bites...Okay
Hebadeh!
Oh you got... Woah! what are you??
Well you're dead! okay...
Ooooaaoooh you guys are so cool!
WooOOaAh! What are YOUUU??!!
That's so cool!!
Look at that!
Look at these monsters
Ain't they adorable??
Why am I collecting their teeth?
That's another question that I have to say
I mean, you all obviously have so many teeth in your head
Like, how many can you spare?
Oh you've probably got lots of teeth if you've gotta spine weapon!
Babiti Babiti Bo- Woah!
Oh, that was just a bride
Well, I mean, a bride with a weird mouth on the top of her head
but a bride nonetheless
Goodbyyye
OoooOOooh
"Nagapendra."
Man these-these characters have weird names
OOoh! Hi!
"Frankenstainna"
*laughing* F-F-Frankenstainna
Weeelll, i-it's bizarre that some of the female monsters in here
are oddly sexy, with weird push-up-bra outfits.
Like this one, and the previous one.
Eehh, well, who am I to complain
Oh god, what is going on here?
Stop tormenting that poor man!
"Faseless and Daddy"
*laughing* "Faseless and Daddy?"
Oh, okay.
Hi?
What the fuck "Mary-Helene?!"
What are you doing?
You're not even m-a monster!
You're just normal!
Except you're hangin' on intestines by the looks of it.
Ok bye!
Ahh, OOoh Woah!
Woah!! "Anunetasta?"
"Ahnunetahsta?"
"Anunetasta." Really?
"Anuntasta"
*laughing*
Euh how inappropriate.
"W-wheel Chairer?"
"Wheel Chairer?!"
"Wheel Chairer?!?"
That's a mon-? I just feel bad!
Why am I beating up a monster in a wheel chair??
*regretful Mark groaning*
The game made me do it!
Oh, you're new
"Terror Handler"
Well, euugh! What's wrong with your head?
I mean, you tried to wear a bag over your head, but it didn't work dude.
Just cover it all up, we don't want to see it.
Ooooh, 'Furry of blows?'
I don't have that yet!
I don't want that yet.
But I got another Cobra
Okay, you're dead.
Woah! "Chest?" Does that mean you have a treasure??
Can I have you?
No it was filled with lies.
Are you a Boss? "Boss Wulpunteraunt"
Alright, let's go for it!
PaAAaAaAaAAAAaaaaaaaAAAaAiaAiaAIIIIAiiiii
BulalaerlelallalelaAlLALlaEREIAaliAIliaIAl
mLuluLUlulLULUluluLULUlulMLUMLULMULUmlumlulum
Oh man, dare I go for the mythical triple click?
Nah, too much
Okay
I got some teethes!
My God, this poor guy
I'm just emptying the entirety of his blood everywhere
"Pet Unlocked: Lilith?"
That's not a pet! Oh, is that a doll?
(quiety) Euugh I don't like that.
'Kay, what does Sundew do?
Oh okay, just a lot of damage.
Alrighty then.
Okay, next level
Hi! Welcome to the forest, I suppose!
Prepare to die!
Man, I don't know why I was welcoming myself
to the forest, because obviously it's your home!
I'm just intruuuUUuuuding.
WhA-WhAt a- You're just- You're just a l- You're just a tiger tamer!
You're literally! You-you're just an entertainer
Why am I killing you "Hannah?"
Or-Uh is your name "Meow?"
In some weird twist?
I don't know...
I'm not a hundred percent on this one
Wha- "Schvetsklund?"
What are you doing with that poor man?
OOuuh Okay bye! Whoah!
Hey "Dirty Tricker!"
Well, why am I here?
And what happened to your eyeballs?
And what a lovely balloon you've got there...
How many people have you killed?
Oh, what's that?
Oh! thank you!
Why was that there?
I-I don't know why that was
Okay...
I had to turn off the damage effects because it was actually
lagging my computer, so I'm just gonna do the numbers for now.
And it was also getting in the way of the monsters.
Hebedeh Hebedeh... Woah!
(said with a lisp) "Lesesleth"
(slight lisp) Is that your name, "Lesesleth?"
Have a good day "Lesesleth," you're gonna die.
'Flurry of blows,' first act of ability is available now!
I don't know what that means!
"Hot key: one. Automatically clicks 10 once a second for 30 seconds."
Ha! OOOoooooh! Nice!
Nice!
Nice!!
Killin' it! Killin' them!
Killin' em' dead!!
That's handy. That-that's a lot of- that's a lot of active abilities, I mean honestly!
This is awesome!
I LuUhuhhuhuuhuHOOoooove it!
"Flurry of blows is over"
Man, ten minute cool down? Hot tits
Okay, I think we've got another Boss after this
So "Hellblader" I'll be with you in a second
WwwOOOoooAAh! "Boss Lord Croak!"
"Boss Lord Croak!!"
Oh god, am I gonna beat this one??
I dunno if I can even beat this one!
Holy shit- ah shit!
AAAaaaaAAaaaAahHhHHhh!!
Oh boy! I'm not gonna make this one!
Wooooah I am not gonna make this one
I'm not ready!
(kinda high pitched) Ahhhhh I'm not ready!!
Dammit I need like- I shouldn'- I shouldn't have wasted my 'Flurry of blows. '
Okay, now I'm doing, like, double clicking damage
so I think I should be able to go to the next place
so...
Bring it on "Boss Lord Croak!"
Yeah, this time I've got ya!
This time I got ya!
EuuAAh Gotta keep up the pace though!
EEUUAaaalittle bit longer!
AAAaaaAAAaaAAHHHAHhhhh You better give me a lotta teeth after this
because if I don't get it... aAaauuwww
Holy shiiiiiiit
Eh
Eu
AAaaAAaaaaAAAhHhhHHh Da!
Okay, got it. How many did that-
Woah! that was a lot of teeth!
Okay
So if I buy...
More of these bad-boys... Another LIlith
Maybe it'll be fast enough to actually kill you alone.
Probably the best money is just farming bosses but I dunno.
I think at this point,
Like my pets have far out-paced what I can do by myself
Because they seem...
They seem to be...
Killing these guys pretty dead
Pretty capably
Ahh!
Alright what I'm gonna do is, I'm gonna- woah
'Head unlock: Jester's Chest?'
I don't have 100,000 yet
Let me get the "Cyberworm" first!!
I'm gonna do...
Uh..
Two things:
I'm gonna get to the next level,
I'm gonna get the "Cyberworm,"
And then...
I'm gonna unlock 'Flurry of Bloooooows'
Uplon the bloss-
Uplon the bluhublubluh
Woooooah!!!
You look awesome!
You look AWEsome!!!
I can't believe I'm still finding new monsters!
It's got a thousand DPS
That's a LOT of "dipus."
That's a LOOOT of "dipus."
It's now 19% of my c-current total DPS
Wooah
Scorpion is 45% of my current DPS
That's awesome.
It's awesome
Boink
I wish it had a HunieCam feature
Where you can just click and hold
Like...
Uh..
For a slightly reduced speed but
Y'know
Just something so I don't kill my fingers
Like I always do in these clicker games...
Alright it's time for 'flurry of bloooows'
Bring it on boss!!
WOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!
Oh god, It's not enough
OH GOD!
"Boss Hammer Vielder."
I feel like this game was made in Germany
Because all the names seem to [be] very Germanic names
"HAHMEHR VIELDHER!"
UND (literally incomprehensible)!
Yea, that's not gonna work
Even 'Flurry of Blows' isn't good enough...
Alright fine, I'll leeeave
Man, I have not even TOUCHED these achievements.
Holy shit!
How are you supposed to get...?
Oh my god!
What is th-, what does 'N' mean?
What does 'S' mean?!
Those aren't...
Th-Those aren't...
THOSE AREN'T numbers!!!
Those are NOTHING!!
Oh god
500,000...
5 Billion
500 Quintillion
50 Thousand Quintillion
I don't even KNOW what that is!
Holy shit, these numbers!
How can they even GET this high?
Oh my GAAAAAWD
I'm just gonna beat this one last boss,
and then I'm gonna end the episode.
I've been playing this way too long. I did NOT expect to be playing this
THIS long. It's weirdly addictive just like 'Cookie Clicker' is.
So i-it's just kind of fun to play, I don't know why. I don't know why
Don't blame me.
Don't judge me for this!
I can have guilty pleasures too...
Clickin' monsters to death...
Seeing the occasional boob, it's nice.
Ok, so while that's farming for me, let's look through more of these achievements
cause holy shit there are a lot of achievements.
Kill 10 bosses...
Kill 100 bosses...
Kill 1000 bosses...
How are you supposed to kill 100,000 bosses
when I've only killed 32?
Gimmie that!
Thank you!
I don't know why the hell I keep getting those things,
but thank you!
Maybe it's because I've been playing so long, dammit!
Ah, it's cool, though.
Thank you for that, I needed it.
Alright I'm gonna upgrade...
Scorpio
He seems pretty cool.
Eyuh!
And then
HA-booski!
Now he's...
wow
Every time I upgrade one of these things
they end up being my top DPS by a long shot.
Ah this should be enough!
I'm gonna BEAT this fricken boss!
ugUAHHHHHHHHH
C'MON!
Oooooh this is gonna be close!
Oh, I gotta keep up the speed,
keep up the speed, keep up the speed.
whew
Ahhh my fingers are crampin'!
Ahh okay, fingers crampin'!
OHH DON'T SLOW DOWN! DON'T SLOW DOWN! DON'T SLOW DOWN! DON'T SLOW DOWN!
Almost there!
Just a LITTLE BIT LONGER!
AAAAAGH
GODDAMMIT!
HUAAAAGH
Aww yeeaaaah baby!
*still screaming*
*panting*
Goddamnit, that was hard.
Heh heh. That was legitimately hard.
Ow, my hands...
Holy shit, I think I need a break.
I just need to let this game play itself for a little bit
Agh, good GOD!
Holy SHIT my hand!
AAAGH.
But I did it!
Thaaaat's good!
Mmkay.
Now I can get this.
BOINK
Alright, got that!
Now that's doin' 30% of my damage.
A lot more than it was before.
I'm gonna get Sundew up to 25 next...
Then...
HA-booski!
Yeeeah!
Now we're doin' some serious 'dipus.'
I can't help it, guys!
I can't help it.
I'm gonna play up to 25.
I wanna see the next boss.
I like this game a loooot!
I-It's something about these clicker games that like,
scratch that certain itch.
It's like an illusion of progress.
It's not REALLY progress.
You're just fighting, you know, up.
The numbers get bigger and bigger,
but the numbers getting bigger is it's own reward.
So it's kinda cool in that aspect, so,
Well, whatever. Hup!
Oh, hey "Chest!"
Thank you!
Oooooh!
That's a lot of muns!
That's nice.
I've collected a million teeth!
Good for me!
I feel SO accomplished!
HooRAY!!!
Oh boy....
OOOH! Oooooh that sounds cool!
"Snake poison potency."
"Click damage increased by .5% of current DPS."
So that means that I'll always have more.
I want that next.
I want that definitely. Definitely. Deeefinite-
Almost, almost...
and...
Little more, little more, little more, little more, little more...
HABOOSKI
And that'll do it.
BOINK
And now my blade damage is...
not all that much increased!
But that allows for exponential growth in the future, I guess.
So that was definitely worth it.
Ok, so I've been playing for quite awhile
I'm next to the boss
Uh, this one's gonna be a tough one,
Because it's getting exponentially more required to get higher up on the scale
But that's ok!
Because I'm about to get-
No, I already did that,
I'm about to get...
prooobably Lilith up to 25
I think this is gonna be the next thing that's gonna be the most beneficial to me
Babidah-babidah
Babidababidaba
Boink
Okay and a
BOINK
And then,
she's now doing 25%.
This just means that we're doing a lot more.
We're up to-
I just should look at the numbers.
We're doing 96,000 DPS.
Which is
HELLA GOOD.
I shouldn't say the word hella...
Alright, we can at least see where we stand on the boss
Oh, hello!
Woahhh you're so cool looking!
But I'm nowhere close to beating you...
Wooooow!
I'm doooomed!
Ok screw that.
Titan strength? HELL YEAH!
Ooo, increases your DPS by 100%
Ok, if I do that, AND 'flurry of blows,' AND this little guy
I think I can beat the boss.
I'm pretty sure that's going to be enough to be able to smash...
everybody up a storm.
Ok, you ready? Here we go.
Boink, boink-boink
Gimmie. Gimmie the thing
Do the thing, do the thing, do the thing, do the thing!
AHHH do the thing!
Do the thing with the bug!
There we go!
"Hellish Riddle." I don't know what that means.
What does that mean?
What does that mean? What is a hellish rishle?
I don't know, but I'm doing this.
Aw shit, is my DPS gonna keep up long enough?
AHHHHH shit.
gaaAAAAHHHHk
AHHHHHHHRIGHT
AAAAAAAAANNNNND
SCHABAAAAM
Okay...Hot damn!
That guy gave like half a million...
Half a million!
And we went up to a roof sanctum!
Ok!
So that's where I'm gonna end this episode,
I've been playing this for damn near an hour, because
I have nothing better to do with my time, apparently.
but this is fun!
I will not deny,
For a free game, and for a clicker game,
this is pretty cool!
There's a lot of avenues and progression,
it's got a lot of diversity to it,
It's not bad!
I like it a lot.
It's pretty cool.
Ok. Teeth knocker...?
What does that mean?
Does that mean more toothes???
Oh, god! I gotta take advantage of this!
Ok! So
thank you everybody so much for watching!
If you want to play this game,
there will be a link in the description below,
it's available on Steam,
and thanks again for watching!
And as always, I will see you...
in the next video! Buh-bye!
*outro music kicks in*